مفسدون في الارض واعداء الله مصطلحاتهم
يستخدمها النظام الايراني لوصف المتظاهرين
في الانتفاضه الحاليه في كل يوم يزداد فيه
زخم الاحتجاجات تزيد وحشيه رد فعل النظام
تكتيكات جديده تتبعها قوات الامن اخرها
مسيرات تحلق على علو منخفض فوق رؤوس
المتظاهرين وتفتح النيران عليهم
[تصفيق]
اما في محطه المترو التي تعتبر من نقاط
الاحتجاج الساخنه كما قصص قوات الامن
كفيلا ببث الذعر والتدافع بين المتظاهرين
لم يسلم حرموا الجامعه بلطاله العوف وضرب
الطلاب والاعتقال
[موسيقى]
من ساحات الاحتجاج الى المعتقل ومن مواجهه
العنف الى التهم الجاهزه قد يكون مصير
المتظاهرين الاعدام القضاء الايراني
من وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
بهدف اثاره الاضطراب
[موسيقى]
مشاهد ليست جديده فالتاريخ يكرر نفسه بما
يشبه احتجاجات نوفمبر 2019
والتي تسببت بمقتل اكثر من 1000 شخصا
واعتقال الالاف الا ان ساحه العنف في
الاحتجاجات الحاليه اوسع اذا عمر العربيه